after three years and more than two and
a half million expulsions it's over the
title 42 Public Health order that turned
into a near blanket ban on Asylum
Seekers on the US's Southern border is
gone but many migrants are now wondering
and worrying about the new rules which
are replacing it
in a tank camp in Juarez North Mexico in
the shadow of the Border Jeremy from
Venezuela was trying to use a U.S
government app called cbp1 when we met
him under the new regulations the app's
now the only way for most migrants to
ask for Asylum appointments
it only works in Mexico and although
original glitches have been ironed out
after a month using it Jeremy still
can't get an appointment
a lot of people say they're going
through the jungle is the hardest part
but it's not the hardest part is Mexico
and this app you know that in two or
three days you'll cross the jungle but
you never know when you get an
appointment and it's like a wait on you
there are other new rules too migrants
will be barred from asylum in the U.S if
they can't show they've requested it in
other countries up the route Mexico for
example
Civil Society organizations so that
carries a logistical and security issues
there's also no resources the Kumar
right now is stretched then with record
numbers of requests for Asylum and then
let's talk about security you know a lot
of the people waiting for these
resolutions are waiting in chapas one of
the poorest states in Mexico many of
them cross over to Tabasco one of the
most dangerous states in terms of a
division with uh Narco groups fighting
each other for territory and that's
where we see one of the highest levels
of reported kidnappings which we already
know largely gone reported many migrants
try to get across into the US before the
new post title 42 Rules came into effect
even wading across Rivers Testament to
their worry about what came next
now there's a lull on the border cities
like Juarez that usually witness heavy
migrant flow are quiet for now but that
might not last long activists and even
Mexican officials have told us that once
people get used to the changes numbers
could and probably will go up again this
is the latest of so many attempts from
the US to shore up its Southern border
but there are 22 million displaced
people in the Americas violence poverty
these are the fuels that continue to
push them towards the states
foreign
as of Friday they faced another obstacle
on their way there the Mexican
Government again detaining hundreds of
migrants heading through the south of
the country helping its neighbor to the
north as it continues to try and control
its border John Holman Al Jazeera Sierra
Juarez